kerzen kekse chaos schauen wir mal auch
die korona weihnacht deutschlandkarte
wer darf was wann und wo am mittwoch
erst haben sich bund und länder auf
verschärfte kontakt beschränkungen ab
dem 28 dezember gar nicht durch drei
bundesländer sprechen schon vor in
hamburg gelten die verschärften regeln
schon ab dem 24 12 also ab morgen dann
dürfen sich maximal zehn geimpften oder
gelesene privat treffend für restaurants
kneipen und bars gilt ab 23 uhr eine
sperrstunde ausnahme der neujahrsmorgen
dann dürfen sie bis 1 uhr offen bleiben
außerdem gilt tanzverbot auch in
mecklenburg-vorpommern gelten die
verschärften kontakt beschränkungen
schon ab heiligabend in brandenburg ab
montag niedersachsen hat ab heiligabend
eine zehntägige weihnachtsruhe
angekündigt obwohl da die
hospitalisierung incidents jahr am
niedrigsten ist wie wir gesehen haben
clubs und discos bleiben zu private
treffen sind mit maximal 25 personen
erlaubt veranstaltungen mit mehr als 500
menschen sind verboten versuchen wir das
alles mal einzuordnen und zwar mit
thorsten frei dem parlamentarischen
geschäftsführer der unionsfraktion im
bundestag guten morgen herr frei guten
morgen herr kausch befreien lassen sie
sich an weihnachten die impfpässe ihrer
gäste zeigen
nein das hängt aber auch damit zusammen
dass wir weihnachten sehr traditionell
in der familie feiern und deswegen in
einem kleinen kreis sind wir kennen alle
die die da sind eltern geschwisterkinder
natürlich und insofern passen wir uns
der aktuellen situation an weil es muss
natürlich klar sein und das gilt für
alle menschen bei uns im land die
omikron variante rollt auf uns zu wir
haben ganz kurze verdopplung zeiten und
deswegen ist es ganz wichtig dass
unabhängig von den regeln jedoch
versucht sich so verantwortungsvoll wie
möglich zu verhalten
dann wünschen wir ihnen jetzt schon mal
ein schönes weihnachtsfest der frei ist
wünsche ich ihnen und auch danke schön
sprechen wir aber noch kurze ein
bisschen weiter sie haben einen 17
fragekatalog einen brief an den
bundeskanzler an die bundesregierung
geschickt darin schreiben sie wörtlich
die bürger fragen sich mit recht ob die
bundesregierung alles nötige unmögliche
zur bekämpfung der pandemie unternimmt
das heißt sie sind für härtere maßnahmen
als die jetzt beschlossenen kontakt
beschränkungen was ja dann wieder nur in
lockdown übersetzt werden könnte
nicht automatisch aber sie sehen ja an
den verhandlungen der
ministerpräsidenten zu beginn der woche
dass nicht alle länder mit der situation
zufrieden sind wir haben protokoll
erklärungen beispielsweise des
freistaates sachsen oder des landes
baden württemberg deren
ministerpräsidenten darauf hingewiesen
haben dass die aktuelle pandemie lage in
ihren ländern jedenfalls einen größeren
instrumentenkasten erfordert das sehe
ich das sieht die unionsfraktion
insgesamt auch so ich glaube dass dort
wo wir hohe instanzen hohe
hospitalisierungen haben und
insbesondere auch die zahlen der
patienten in den krankenhäusern nicht
zurückgehen dass wir dort im zweifel den
ländern auch zusätzliche möglichkeiten
geben müssen und es geht nicht darum
dass der bund so etwas vorgibt sondern
es geht darum dass wir den ländern dort
wo wir hoch incidents gebiete haben auch
tatsächlich die instrumente geben von
denen sie glauben dass sie notwendig
sind und winfried kretschmann
beispielsweise bekanntlich kein
ministerpräsident unserer partei hat
explizit gefordert dass die
möglichkeiten des § 28a des
infektionsschutzgesetzes voll zur
verfügung stehen sollen und es bedeutet
eben auch die möglichkeit dass man
veranstaltungen komplett verbieten kann
das bedeutet dass man bestimmte
einrichtungen schließen kann wenn das
die pandemische lage erfordert und ich
glaube dass man das in den ländern
besser entscheiden kann als aus berlin
heraus gestern haben wir ja bayerns
ministerpräsident müller gehört er hat
ganz klar gesagt also wir können auch
nicht alles hier in den bundesländern
regeln es muss schon auch vom bund was
kommt man hat zwischendrin das gefühl
dass ich da der ball so ein bisschen hin
und her gespielt wird die länder sagen
der bund muss nach essen der bundestag
die ländern was machen und am ende
stehen wir bürgerinnen und bürger daran
fragen uns ja was ist denn jetzt wo darf
ich denn jetzt ein weihnachten bier
trinken gehen und wie lange überhaupt
das kann ich absolut nachvollziehen das
ist ja auch unverständlich sie haben sie
in ihrem beitrag gezeigt deswegen ich
glaube für die akzeptanz der maßnahmen
ist es ganz wichtig dass es einen
einheitlichen rahmen gibt den
gesetzlichen rahmen den formuliert der
bund der bundestag im
infektionsschutzgesetz und darüber
hinaus versucht die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die
maßnahmen der länder so weit zu
koordinieren dass es am ende auch
überschaubar bleibt und da glaube ich
ist es wichtig dass die grundlinien
vergleichbar sind die karte die sie
vorher eingeblendet haben zeigt ja auch
wir haben bis auf den äußersten
nordwesten im grunde genommen eine
wirklich schwierige situation in ganz
deutschland und dann brauchen wir glaube
ich darüber hinaus inzidenz abhängig in
den hotspots weitere möglichkeiten
handlungsspielräume vor ort ich finde
der föderalismus er darf in der pandemie
bekämpfung nicht zum nachteil gereichen
sondern wir müssen seine vorteile nutzen
und ob wir das wirklich schon mit voller
kraft tun da darf man nach den
beschlüssen von dienstag glaube ich
durchaus seine zweifel haben
gleichzeitig er freie werfen sie in
ihrem schreiben der bundesregierung und
dem bundeskanzler vor dass sie nur
passiv zuschauen würden was da jetzt
passiert insbesondere im hinblick auf
die abstimmung über die impfpflicht die
ja im bundestag stattfinden soll aus dem
bundestag heraus nachdem freien wissen
und gewissen der abgeordneten was kann
daran falsch sein
also zunächst einmal ist es so dass
jeder abgeordnete selber entscheidet ob
es sich bei der vorliegenden
entscheidungen um eine
gewissensentscheidung handelt oder nicht
wir haben nämlich gott sei dank keinen
fraktionszwang sondern jeder abgeordnete
jeder abgeordnete ist in der lage und
ihr wird es und ihm auch gestattet nach
dem eigenen gewissen abzustimmen
aber der punkt ist doch folgender die
frage ob wir eine allgemeine impfpflicht
in deutschland bekommen ist eine
überhaupt nicht triviale das ist in
höchstem maße anspruchsvoll das hat auch
das ad hoc gutachten des ethikrates
diese woche noch einmal gezeigt wie wir
haben es hier mit einem
grundrechtseingriff zu tun der aber ganz
sicher gesetzlich gerechtfertigt werden
kann davon bin ich überzeugt weil der
freiheits schutz der schutz der
unversehrtheit der gesundheit letztlich
ja ein schutz ist den alle menschen
genießen also nicht nur die geimpften
sondern auch die ungeimpften aber so
etwas muss man sehr sorgfältig machen
das sind viele fragen zu klären was
heißt denn endlich erste zweite dritte
vierte impfung in welchen abständen ist
das zu machen welche konsequenzen hat
eine nichtbeachtung und vieles andere
mehr welche ausnahmen gibt es
beispielsweise und da finde ich es
fahrlässig als bundesregierung wenn man
es selber für notwendig hält am rand zu
stehen und zu sagen ich warte jetzt mal
ab welche anträge dazu aus dem bundestag
kommen ich finde wenn eine
bundesregierung davon überzeugt ist dass
eine maßnahme notwendig ist dann muss
sie auch einen gesetzlichen vorschlag
machen wie soetwas rechtssicher und
verfassungsgemäß umgesetzt werden kann
und nichts anderes erwarte ich von der
bundesregierung dass am ende natürlich
jeder abgeordnete so abstimmen kann wie
er es für richtig hält das ist doch
völlig unbenommen aber es ist wirklich
einzigartig dass eine bundesregierung in
einer zentralen politischen frage an der
seitenlinie steht die arme verschränkt
und sagt ich warte jetzt mal was im
bundestag passiert ist das keine führung
von vorne und das ist genau das was wir
in dieser pandemie jetzt benötigt